[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
christelle vous vous faites chier dans
votre vie on est en 2001 j'ai 31 ans je
suis dans le cabinet de mon généraliste
et voilà ce qu'il me dit alors je suis
en train de lui dire que j'en peux plus
que je suis épuisée entre mes trois
filles en bas âge mon boulot dans lequel
je suis très engagé
ma famille ma maison bref j'en peux plus
je sors de son cabinet furieuse mais
c'est qui ce connard
pour qui se prend il
bon je vous explique maintenant à
l'origine je suis l'aîné d'une famille
catholique de quatre enfants d'origine
lyonnaise
j'ai grandi en région parisienne j'ai
fait des études de finance à
l'université paris dauphine dont je suis
diplômée d'un master de marchés
financiers j'ai démarré ma vie
professionnelle dans une banque
d'affaires reconnu
je me suis marié à 25 ans pour la vie et
en même temps j'ai aussi mis au monde
trois enfants en deux ans et demi
puisque j'ai eu la chance d'en faire
deux d'un coup bref une vie qui me
semble tout tracé et je crois que c'est
en juillet 2001 que ça commence à se
dérégler au fond de mon lit avec une
belle engine et moi je suis jamais
malade mais bon trois semaines de
vacances en août ça va alléger la vie
d'une jeune mère de famille bien engagée
dans sa vie professionnelle
c'est normal et me voilà sur ma plage
préférée avec mes amis ma famille et
comme on dit j'ai tout pour être
heureuse la photo de famille est
parfaite et pourtant je me demande bien
ce que je fous là je me sens l'as épuisé
je m'ennuie et il m'ennuie tous
profondément mais imaginez c'est le truc
impossible à dire
je me dis ça va alléger trois semaines
devant moi je vais pouvoir me reposer
non non pas du tout les semaines passent
et c'est toujours pareil et la rentrée
se profile et je vais devoir y retourner
et l'horreur j'y retourne septembre une
boule dans le ventre ont cette fois ci
je me dis que faut peut-être que j'aille
chez le médecin le fameux là le connard
il me connaît bien puisqu'il passe sa
vie à la maison pour soigner mes trois
sauterelles et cette fois ci je vais y
aller pour moi j'arrive je lui raconte
mes vacances
ma rentrée il prend la tension 8 de
tension ah ben c'est pas étonnant
vous allez me donner des vitamines et
puis c'est bon je vais repartir je vais
vous donner des médicaments et ne
serviront à rien c'est quoi ce médecin
gelé prendre ses médicaments et puis ça
va aller je prends les médicaments et
effectivement il a raison ça sert à rien
donc j'y retourne toujours 8 de tension
et c'est là où il me dit christelle vous
faites chier dans votre vie et moi je
lui dis mais non c'est pas possible je
me fais pas chier dans ma vie j'ai pas
une minute à moi qu'est ce que vous me
racontez bon je vais vous prescrire un
bilan sanguin
ah bah enfin vous prenez au sérieux
enfin il fait son job de médecins alors
je vais faire mon analyse de sang je
vous raconte pas comme je suis pressé
pour aller chercher les résultats et
quand j'arrive joie la tête de la
laborantine décomposer je me dis ça doit
être grave je vois les résultats elle me
dit j'espère que vous vous faites suivre
ben oui bien sûr je me vois déjà avec
une leucémie au j'y retourne je vais le
voir furieuse vous avez vu c'est marqué
sur le papier je suis malade je vous
l'avais bien dit regardez les résultats
je le sens de venir tout penaud se
rétrécir bon on va faire des examens
complémentaires ah bah oui c'est pas
trop tôt on a perdu un peu de temps il
aura fait peut-être fallu commencer par
là et le lendemain je m'effondre
impossible de me lever son diagnostic
burn out et dépression
là je lui dis non pas possible c'est pas
moi je vais aller faire les autres ces
examens en cherchant par tous les moyens
un autre diagnostic
les médecins vont parler d'un virus qui
va mettre des mois à s'en aller
je vais dormir pendant trois mois oui
heureusement j'avais une bonne nounou à
l'époque trois mois au fond de mon lit
avec des antidépresseurs des
anxiolytiques et des somnifères et avec
ce cocktail molotov je vais pouvoir
dormir le jour surtout la nuit c'est
l'insomnie peu à peu quand même les
médicaments font effet
et je commence à reprendre de l'énergie
est au bout des trois mois je peux vous
dire que je me sens en pleine forme
j'appelle mon patron je lui dis ça y est
c'est bon j'ai eu un passage à vide
j'étais fatigué je prends tous les
médicaments poubelles et j'y retourne
wonder woman est reparti et je replonge
imaginez vous voyez le plongeoir 3 m à
la piscine mais la première fois je
pense que j'ai sauté de là cette fois ci
c'est du 20 mètres avec un plat à
l'arrivée je me sens plonger plonger
comme dans un puits sans fond je réussis
presque plus à sortir je me sens
agressée par le monde extérieur
allez dans un supermarché c'est
l'horreur et un jour au volant de ma
voiture j'ai même envie d'en finir et
donné un coup de volant pour aller dans
le ravin et pourtant j'ai trois enfants
pour la première fois de ma vie je
comprends ce qu'ils en viennent à se
suicider
je suis au fond mon lit et je pleure je
pleure toutes les larmes de mon corps
comment est ce possible que ça m'arrive
à moi parce que moi je suis une femme
forte
moi j'ai fait cinq ans à dauphine j'ai
trois enfants j'ai un mari j'ai une
famille j'ai des amis ça peut pas
m'arriver à moi ça
mes amis pour la première fois de ma vie
j'expérimente les limites de ma nature
humaine
j'expérimente les limites de ma tête qui
décide qui organise qui planifie qui
contrôle sans écouter mon coeur sans
écouter mon corps et j'accepte d'aller
chez le psy parce que tous me disent que
c'est chez un psy que je dois aller me
faire soigner mais un psy vous imaginez
pour moi à cette époque c'était
inenvisageable sepsis était fait pour
ceux qui avaient des problèmes pour ce
qu'elle n'est pas bien dans leur tête
mais moi j'avais pas de problème j'étais
juste fatigué trois grossesses en deux
ans et demi un boulot de malades voilà
quoi
c'est mon corps qui me lâche et je rends
les armes
j'accepte de prendre les médicaments
j'accepte d'aller chez 7 6 alors oui j'y
vais à reculons et et même j'ai honte
ça me va bien je me cache derrière sa
plaque a marqué médecins généralistes
alors pour moi je vais chez le médecin
c'est tout et je vais mettre des années
à dire qu'elle est psychiatre
les psychiatres pour moi c'est
l'équivalent de sainte-anne c'était les
fous et puis me voilà j'y vais première
séance je vois arriver une petite femme
peu comme moi sympathique me met tout de
suite à l'aise elle confirme le
diagnostic des autres ça s'apprend pas
tant mais bon on va pas s'éterniser là
dessus et puis elle m'offre une clope
une clope chez un médecin et un psy
finalement être un peu fou c'est pas mal
non
et nous voilà toutes les deux en train
de fumer notre club
c'était peut-être pour me préparer à la
question que j'ai pas vu venir
christelle qu'est ce que vous voulez bah
moi qu'est ce que je veux j'ai un beau
job dans la finance
marie trois enfants des amis une famille
voilà ce que je veux
non christelle qu'est ce que vous voulez
vous de quoi avez vous envie j'écrase ma
clope
qu'est ce que je veux moi et moi j'en
sais rien je me retrouve dans la rue
face à ce vide qui m'envahit moi j'ai
fait des études de finance parce que
c'est bien sur un cv ça fait bien si on
gagne bien sa vie il n'y a pas de
chômage
je me suis marié j'ai fait des enfants
d'à comme tout le monde j'ai choisi la
route
et puis le business plan est mal est
bien ce que je veux moi j'ai 31 ans
c'est la première fois de ma vie que je
me pose cette question et c'est comme si
elle était en train de remettre en
question tout ce que j'ai fait jusqu'à
présent
imaginez je suis déjà bien engagé où
tous les lundis je vais y aller tous les
lundis soir après le boulot je peux pas
vous dire ce qu'on s'est dit mais je
peux vous dire sexe pour la première
fois de ma vie c'est des rendez-vous où
on ne parle que de moi et tous moi eh
bien imaginez un endroit où on ne parle
que de vous et tous vous et bien ça vous
est déjà arrivé sans qu'on vous dise que
vous êtes égoïstes nombriliste
égocentrique et ça me fait du bien
oui ça me fait tellement de bien
alors très vite la question
professionnelle arrive sur le tapis bah
oui 50 heures par semaine c'est un vrai
sujet et ça fait des années que c'est
bien que ça cloche la finance les
chiffres ça jamais été mon truc mais bon
quoi faire d'autre et elle elle me parle
de plaisir au travail
elle me dit que c'est possible d'avoir
du plaisir au travail plaisir au travail
vous en avez vous
moi à ce moment là
oui j'en ai avec les gens avec qui je
bosse mais je sais pas comment c'est
possible je sais rien faire d'autre
et puis un jour avec des amis ils me
disent mais christelle pourquoi tu
ferais pas un bilan de compétences
bilan une compétence non mais ça va pas
la tête je vous rappelle que j'ai fait
cinq ans à dauphine mois bilan
d'incompétence oui toute façon j'ai
toujours entendu que ça sert à rien et
givet et là je rencontre armelle val de
vaud steen et encore aujourd'hui je dis
merci
arnel deuxième rendez vous on ne parle
que de moi et ou tout mois
et bien ça c'est top
et en plus armelle me révèle qu'il y a
des choses en moi incroyable et c'est
chose en moi elle les appelle des
talents j'ai des talents alors je vais
pas tout vous raconter ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que cette première étape
qui fut quand même le début d'un long
cheminement compliqué a duré un an
au bout d un an j'ai réussi à retrouver
en moi de quoi tenir debout tout seul
c'est à dire que j'ai réussi à me
libérer des médicaments grâce à ses
rendez vous avec moi même j'ai retrouvé
un chemin de vie je me suis mise en
mouvement
j'ai quitté la banque j'ai créé mon
propre projet professionnel dont je suis
devenu l'auteur l'acteur encore
aujourd'hui l'actrice même où j'ai du
plaisir j'ai déménagé
bref j'ai repris les rênes de ma vie je
me suis remise en mouvement un an le
début d'une nouvelle page de vie dont je
récolte encore les fruits aujourd'hui
j'ai appris à prendre rendez vous avec
moi même et aujourd'hui encore dans mon
agenda
j'ai des rendez vous avec moi même que
j'appelle des journées désert
et grâce à ces journées désert c'est une
journée par mois au même titre que mes
rendez vous professionnel une journée
que pour moi où je coupe le téléphone où
je coupe internet
je le consacre à ce qui me fait du bien
à ce dont j'ai envie pour moi et j'ai
découvert ce que j'aurais jamais imaginé
des talents d'artiste j'ai réalisé un
jour une peinture une petite fille avec
une petite robe rouge tout perdu au
milieu d'un paysage de montagne et j'ai
vu dans cette petite fille ma petite
fille intérieur que j'avais complètement
abandonné j'ai mis aussi je
l'accompagnais de massives d'hortensias
derosier j'ai vu là ma capacité
d'émerveillement
mon enthousiasme face à la vie un peu
plus tard j'ai fait une panthère
panthères je me suis dit mais qu'est ce
que c'est que ce truc là je suis allé
voir sur internet et j'ai découvert
qu'elle s'appelle panthera pardus
orientalis la panthère de l'amour qui
vit au bord du fleuve amour en sibérie
et qui est menacée d'extinction car elle
est chassé à outrance pour ses vertus
médicinales mes amis j'étais en train de
redonner vie à la panthère de l'amour
incroyable peu plus tard j'ai fait un
hippopotame hippopotames mais je me suis
dit c'est quoi ce zoo pareil je suis
allé voir et là j'ai découvert que
l'hippopotame dans la mythologie
égyptienne pour la femelle est symbole
de fécondité et oui j'étais en train de
vivre pleinement cette nouvelle
fécondité et je sentais dans cet
hippopotame cette force en moi dans
laquelle je peux m'enraciner et qui
m'aident à traverser les tempêtes de ma
vie pourquoi je vous raconte tout ça
parce que je sais quand chacun de vous
il y a ce magnifique jardin intérieur
et quel temps prenez vous avec vous même
pour lui rendre visite pour vous
rencontrer vous allez me dire non mais
christelle une journée par mois
t'es pas bien quoi t'as pas vu mon
emploi du temps c'est pas possible
quel temps prenez-vous chaque jour pour
être avec vous même
et pas seulement pour vous brosser les
dents grâce à ces rendez vous avec moi
même j'ai appris à m'aimer et à me
trouver belle quand je me regarde dans
le miroir sans culpabilité et je sais
que si chacun d'entre nous nous prenons
ce temps pour mieux nous aimer pour
mieux nous respecter pour respecter
notre propre nature
alors chacun chacune
nous serons en mesure de mieux aimer de
mieux respecter la nature avec un grand
n
cette terre sur laquelle nous sommes
locataires et qui elle aussi je crois
est en train de vivre un burn-out car
elle aussi a ses propres limites
avant de partir et vous dire au revoir
je voudrais vous présenter ces quelques
compagnons dont je vous ai parlé et qui
sont venues avec moi
voilà le tableau de ma petite fille
intérieur dont je vous parlais voici
aussi dans ce jardin panthera pardus
orientalis ma panthères de l'amour et
enfin l'hippopotame je vous remercie